Hi everyone. I got invited to train over
a hundred Somali ex-Muslim Christians in
apologetics and pmics, which is
interesting because I didn't know there
were over a hundred Somali ex-Muslim
Christians. I've known two Somali
ex-Muslim Christians for several years,
and they are two of the most amazing
evangelism machines I've ever seen. I do
hear from lots of Somali ex-Muslims in
the comments. Here are a few comments on
a recent video. Ex-Muslim from Somalia.
I left Islam four years ago when I was
20 years old and still no one in my
family and friends knows it yet. Proud
Somali ex-Muslim. Jesus is Lord of Lords
and King of Kings. I'm ex-Muslim from
Somalia. Jesus is the way, the truth,
and the life. We are proud of ourselves.
Jesus over our fear and love over hate.
Hello, I'm nameensensored by me from
Somalia. I've been following your videos
for a while and they've really helped me
in my faith. I was baptized this year on
June 1st and your teachings continue to
inspire me. Thank you for your ministry.
So, we know there are Somali ex-Muslim
Christians, but now they're at the point
where they're getting together for an
annual conference. They asked me if I
would speak at their first conference. I
said, "Absolutely." They asked me how
much I would charge as a speaker's fee.
I told them not to worry about paying me
a dime or about covering any of my costs
because whatever the ministry there is
doing with whatever funding they have,
they're doing some awesome work. So, I
said I would just ask everyone to chip
in to cover the costs of the trip. Then
I said I wanted to bring Anthony Rogers
with me because he's probably the best
at Trinity versus Tawhed discussions. I
also wanted Anthony speaking because the
last time I was heading across the ocean
for a conference, they rejected my
electronic travel agreement right before
I was leaving and I wasn't allowed to
enter the country. That was the UK. But
in case something like that should
happen again with a different country, I
didn't want to leave them without a
speaker at the last minute. The plane
tickets turned out to be more expensive
than I thought. I grabbed tickets for
another country along the way for a
special recording there. But something's
weird because the tickets to go over
there were pretty cheap. Even with
getting to New York and then flying to
two different countries, they added up
to about $1,000 for each of us. But the
only tickets that would get us back in
time for another conference were $1,500
each. Not sure why it's way more
expensive coming back across the
Atlantic. Anyway, just the plane tickets
added up to a little over $5,000
altogether. I don't really care about
any of the other costs, but that's a
pretty big pile of money and I need to
conserve funds right now because we've
got a massive expansion coming at the
end of January. Really, really big. I'll
tell you about that later. I'll just say
now that if you've been paying
attention, you know that 2025 has been
the worst year in DAWA history. Things
have gone bad for them this year. But by
this time next year, they will be
looking back at 2025 as the good old
days because things are going to be way,
way worse next year. So, if everyone can
chip in five or 10 bucks, we should be
able to get these tickets covered. The
give send go link is in the description
and before the end of the year I'll let
you know how you can support the Somali
ex-Muslim Christian ministry that's
doing this amazing work. Somalia really
really needs the gospel. So instead of
freaking out about Ilhan Omar Islamizing
America, let's focus on equipping Somali
Christians to tell their fellow Somali
the truth about Jesus and Muhammad.
[music]